Maddie Kaylee Zanna and Ethan were truly  all one of a kind  [Music]  Susanna and Ethan the two best friends  but perfect pair together  they had this Unstoppable loving  relationship  you all were gifts to this world in your  own special way  and it just won't be the same without  you  [Music]  it didn't appear that there was any  force entry to the home you know there  were two survivors and as well the  actual crime scenes themselves really  lead detectives and the chief to firmly  and continue to believe that this was  targeted  foreign  not in the immediate circle by any means  but a few of the names that have been  circulating around I think it's hard not  to kind of you know dig into this and I  don't know how much of that is just  because we have so little information  from law enforcement